these guys rather unusual they are
marked not like ordinary dice one
through six but in various peculiar
patterns for example this is three
everywhere three three three three three
three
this one has four four four four and
zero zero okay so four four four four
zero zero against the three everywhere
and we play the following game two
players row them against each other and
whichever number comes up higher
wins in this case this one this loss had
it been like this this would have lost
this one of one now we try to rank the
dice compare the dice and see
say which is stronger which is weaker
and here is the definition we say that
one die is stronger than the other die
if that die has a higher probability of
winning against the other die which
means that it wins more frequently
against the die and conversely one of
them is weaker than the other if that
loses more often let's note that we are
not comparing the average scores we are
comparing the probabilities for example
if you had three everywhere and the
other die instead of four four four zero
zero had let's say zero zero zero zero
zero and 10 gazillion of course every
three you know wins more fat the one the
has 10 gazillion has a higher score but
that's a higher average score but that's
not what we're talking about we are
comparing probabilities of winning okay
so which one of these is stronger you
can see that this has four four four
four zero zero and this is three
everywhere
so clearly this wins four out of six
times and loses two out of six times so
this wins more often against this one so
this is stronger than that one
thus the beginning of the totem-pole
ranking is like this this is stronger
than that one let's keep the stronger of
the truth winner and compare it against
this newcomer this newcomer has five
five five and one one one okay five five
five one one one against four four four
four zero zero which one is stronger
well it looks like we have to do
arithmetic that would be a bit ugly I
really may not be so difficult but we
don't want to do so to mess around with
calculations fortunately there is a very
nifty way of arguing qualitatively and
seeing which one is stronger we argue as
follows
you see this
is half of that time it comes up five so
suppose that it comes up five which
happens half of the time well in that
case whatever the other dye does this
has one already yeah because the other
guy has only 4 so 0 so this wins already
half at the time but even if it shows up
one well it still has some nonzero
residual positive probably here winning
if the other one were careless enough to
show zero so it wins 50 percent plus
change so this is strictly stronger than
that one and that's what that's why this
is stronger than the other one well this
is a very nice augment because in the
definition we don't really care by how
much you win all you have to know is
which means more often so we don't have
to calculate the exact probabilities if
you can say well this wins more from
that that's the end of its story
so the totem pole continues like this
this one beats this one and this one
beat this one ok now let's compare this
winner with the newcomer the newcomer
has six six and two two two two two two
two two and six six whereas the previous
champion was five five five one one one
which means more off again it looks like
a matter of arithmetic and we wanted to
avoid arithmetic fortunately there is a
nifty argument which qualitatively
decides which one wins Morphin and it's
the same argument as before but we
applied to the loser this time let's say
that this has shown one this came up one
in which case it's already lost whatever
the other guy does because the other has
only six and twos okay so it has this
one has already lost half of the time at
least half of the time but even if it
shows up five it still has a nonzero
positive ratio probability of losing
against the other one if the other one
were careful enough to show six instead
of two so this one loses 50% of time
plus change so it loses more often than
the other one so this is weaker than the
other that is why this is weaker this is
stronger so this beats this one so far
then we have seen the following rank
this beats this this beats this this
beats this this beats this this piece
this piece
this but now let's compare the two ends
this one has six six two two two two
this was three everywhere which one wins
Morphin of course this one because this
one wins four times art with six when
the other one shows up two and loses
only two times when the other one stitch
all six are the six so the situation is
that this beats this this beats this
this is this but this beats this is a
cycle and we call this a non-transitive
cycle in probabilistic comparisons i
think that this phenomenon done which
has been known for quite a long time but
deserves to be known to everyone really
all citizens the what we are saying is
that you know if you are comparing say
performances of three drugs or something
like that and then you say well a kills
more people than be in some statistical
sample and in other studies go sample
because more people than see you cannot
necessarily conclude that a is better
than C you know a better than B be
better than C does not necessarily when
you're doing comparability comparisons
that a is better than C it might happen
to be true but we are saying that that's
not a logical necessity and in fact this
example shows that you can't conclude
that again I'd like to emphasize that as
long as you're comparing the average
scores this kind of phenomenon never
occurs of course because all the average
scores can be ranked in a linear fashion
but if you are comparing which one is
more fun there's a lot of conditioning
going on and that is why you cannot so
carelessly conclude a better than B be
better than C means that a is better
than C that's not necessarily true
this is called non-transitive dice at
this kind of station is called
non-transitive probabilistic comparison
when you compare probabilities you have
be quite careful and the occurs in all
sorts of serious and interesting
stations have to be fair whereas your
ordinary cube has excessive amounts of
symmetry you could say right I mean this
there's weight there's extra symmetries
like this thing is the same as it's the
same shape but like I haven't it's still
face to